so the big crowd settling in on this
glorious saturday afternoon
and adam frazier's leading off he's done
a nice job
laying down butts
hitting the ball the other way
just like that
broken bat little roller he's got hit
number 60 on the year and he's headed to
second and throws gonna beat it
frazier got a little greedy there thank
you very much
he beats the shift and he's an easy out
at second base and is slow to get up
and frazier he thought he had an
opportunity to get a double
good hustle
nice relay by dansby
good tag by ozzy
so joey cora their third base coach have
his hand up is just to say stop that's a
little difficult to see from third base
right well ronald lacuna junior is going
to lead off
for atlanta
first pitch swing and a rifle shot to
lafayette
it's one to nothing
mistake first pitch toronto raccoon you
cannot miss fastball middle of the plate
he knows exactly what to do with it home
run number 15 for him
what a way to start this game take a
look at this fastball right down the
middle how many times have we seen this
from acuna
this ball was actually torched on a line
to left field
the question was was it going to be high
enough to get out
4-10 on base percentage for austin
reilly
as this one is smoked into center field
a base head here comes freddie around
third there will be no play at the plate
austin reilly with a solid single to
center makes it two to nothing
it does a nice job that's where his
happy zone is right now if it's middle
of the plate he's putting a good swing
on it consistently
things looking up for atlanta and for
freddie freeman individually they enjoy
a two-nothing lead looking for more here
in the second
stroked into left-center field of base
head another two-out run for atlanta
that's going to score ender in ciarte
one rbi for freddie freeman is 29th of
the year and the braves extend the lead
it's three to nothing and that's how you
get your base hits the opposite field
91 runs with two outs for the braves
second only to the dodgers in the
national league
so now here's michael perez
oh for his last 26.
talk about overdue
fly ball to right
and clear the deck with a cannonball his
second
and the pirates are on the board
and he is off the snide
that got to feel pretty good for him to
to break it with a home run
high fastball
his second home run as a pirate
[Music]
granny it's bryce wilson's turn to pitch
it's been a while in the big leagues for
the young right-hander i'm excited to
see him throw again i thought he was
great you know and the time you were
here
you're a veteran player as wilson
strikes out keller for the first time
you can't get what you get in the
clubhouse in a regular job no question
and so that's what brings back those
memories for these guys and it's special
and it's fun
gamble is out on a check swing strikeout
bryce wilson has a one two three fourth
camel and disbelief is rung up
so you got to get on some sort of roll
knowing what the
schedule looks like going forward
a line drive to right field bryce is
aboard polanco plays that on a second
hop
so another two out hit for atlanta
that'll bring up acuna first hit of the
year for bryce wilson
everything that happened to me in my
career he played a huge part in that but
you know one thing i liked about bobby
he said leo there's your pictures take
care of him he said i don't care how you
do it
high towering fly ball by albies to
right polanco is back and that ball is
gone a majestic homer for ozzy albees
that extends the lead and the ball is
flying in atlanta two more homers for
the braves
in game three
that's a happy place nick for a
left-hand hitter and right there
i mean he's got so much power from the
left side too and that's what you don't
want to see him
think about so much such a great
baseball town
for them not to have the club to compete
on a yearly basis
[Applause]
gamble is down on strikes change up got
him that's two strikeouts of gamble two
outs in the inning
he's skied hard toward left center field
and deep look at that ball carry out
toward the wall it's gone
it's a two homer dave for ozzy obese
boy he has gotten hotter than the
georgia asphalt from the right side of
the plate nine homers 24 rbis for the
braves cleanup man and they are mixing
it up again
look at this swing
you try to come in on ozzy the hands are
tight to the body
[Applause]
beautiful extension got off the back
side i love it
when he's swinging the bat well
it's so exciting it's so fun and
obviously they're having fun in the
dugout as well but
guys he's he's grown on me so much he's
got will craig in the batter's box craig
is one for two of the walk and a seventh
inning single
and ball four brings craig to first base
ben gamble is the pirate hitter
last year luke jackson had the long
flowing brunette locks
i like this hair better
lied and caught at second sharply hit
gammel out of luck today one out
nice job by ozzy reacting to his right
so luke is neutralizing left-handed
hitters of late now he's got wilmer
defoe defoe one for three
or a line drive to left on the first
pitch another opposite field head he
smacked the 95 mile an hour fastball the
other way
first pitch fastball up and away
just shoot to the left field and so two
on one out and
michael perez is the batter left-handed
hitter homart in the third
oh and two he went around blew it right
on by at 95 miles an hour and now the
braves run out of way three really good
pitches from luke
slider slider then goes up and in with a
fastball
nothing perez can do
21 pitches for luke jackson facing his
fifth pirate in the ninth inning
frazier on deck
he's scary because he can keep innings
alive he's tough to strike out
vargas has been to the pitch
back where it came from that is hit
toward dansby backhand throw into first
in time and that's your winner
pack got a piece of luke jackson on the
way by but dansby swanson was johnny on
the spot the braves with another
excellent effort have won two in a row
over the pirates this is exactly what
you're supposed to do against a
pittsburgh pirates team that has really
struggled offensively i love the at-bats
again for the fourth day in a row